docteur harper pourquoi pourquoi avoir
attendu six longs mois pour nous dire où
vous en étiez ou dookie tivo passé
je vous inviter à venir ici
m'interviewer dans ma maison
nous avons reçu cette invitation après
que le nombre foudroyant de suicides a
rapidement atteint le million
mais ne pensez vous pas que votre
découverte était en quelque sorte trop
dangereuse pour être divulguées accords
déchets
mais cela
[Musique]
comment garder le secret sur une
découverte aussi vital pour l'être
humain
vous nous avez prouvé l'existence d'un
au delà
je parlerais plutôt d'un nouveau plan
d'existence
qu'est ce que vous vous sentez
responsable revoyez entendre jean mettre
fin à leurs jours
la ouvert les yeux de toutes ces
personnes maintenant il faut leur
montrer ce qu'il ya à voir
[Musique]